teure folgen des debakels die
betreiberfirmen fordern mehr als eine
halbe milliarde euro vom wunsch
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen donald
trump das repräsentantenhaus will den us
präsidenten im senat an klaren und es
geht ja doch benedikt doll schießt
fehlerfrei und holt den ersten deutschen
biathlon sieg in diesem winter
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem donnerstag an meiner seite ist
für den sport christin und voller freude
guten abend als der europäische
gerichtshof vor einem halben jahr die
pkw-maut stoppte da war klar das könnte
teuer werden schließlich hat der
verkehrsminister schon verträge
abgeschlossen jetzt haben die
betreiberfirmen erstmals zahlen auf den
tisch gelegt sie fordern 560 millionen
euro entschädigung vom bund das will
scheuer aber nicht akzeptieren aus
berlin
die pkw maut war das prestige-projekt
der csu jetzt bringt sie den csu
verkehrsminister immer mehr in
bedrängnis über eine halbe milliarde
euro an schadensersatz beanspruchen die
betreiber andreas scheuer lehnt die
forderungen ab die betreiber haben
keinen anspruch auf entschädigung
sie haben ihre vertraglichen leistungen
nicht erfüllt sie haben vertragliche
meilensteine gerissen
der bund hat die verträge aus mehreren
triftigen gründen gekündigt scheuer
hatte nach dem mord aus bereits
unterschriebene verträge gekündigt
strittig ist welche vereinbarungen jetzt
noch gelten von den
betreibergesellschaften eventim und
kapsch trafficcom heute nur ein
schriftliches statement die
vertragsparteien haben für den
vorliegenden fall der vertragsbeendigung
durch den bund den entgangenen gewinn
über die vertragslaufzeit vereinbart
dazu käme noch zusätzlicher
schadensersatz
die opposition sieht die schuld bei
scheuer und fordert den minister
abermals zum rücktritt auf die höhe der
forderung ist ein schwerer schlag für
verkehrsminister scheuer ein ko-schlag
es ist noch höher als erwartet was in
den letzten monaten alles gelaufen ist
das allein hätte schon für drei
ministerrücktritte gereicht und die
letzte ausrede von ihm war ja immer am
ende ist wird gar nicht so teuer werden
für den steuerzahler
das ist glaube ich jetzt auch erledigt
mit dieser forderung am 16 januar trifft
sich der maut untersuchungsausschuss zur
nächsten sitzung ein auftritt von
andreas scheuer ist dort bislang nicht
geplant
was steht an im kommenden jahr darüber
macht sich gerade im kanzleramt der
koalitionsausschuss gedanken vor allem
aber geht es ums kennenlernen denn
erstmals sind den neuen spd chefs dabei
saskia esken und norbert walter borjans
beide sehen die große koalition
skeptisch hatten vor dem treffen aber
schon angekündigt die regierung nicht in
eine so wörtlich schief oder hängen lage
zu bringen
und noch eine bildung aus berlin vom
bundestag der heute wichtige beschlüsse
gefasst hat zum einen den kompromiss
beim klima paket er sieht unter anderem
vor dass die länder vom bund mehr geld
bekommen als ausgleich auch für die
senkung der mehrwertsteuer auf
bahntickets außerdem wölfe dürfen
leichter abgeschossen werden so lange
bis es keine angriffe mehr gibt
allerdings muss jede tötung genehmigt
seien nach washington
seit der nacht ist klar us-präsident
muss sich wegen der ukraine affäre einem
amtsenthebungsverfahren stellen
das hat das repräsentantenhaus mit der
mehrheit der demokraten entschieden
das letzte wort hat allerdings der senat
und da haben jumps republikaner die
mehrheit am versucht jetzt erst recht
seine anhänger zu mobilisieren
ines trams sie feiern ihren präsidenten
auftritt donald trump in michigan weit
entfernt von washington er ist der
dritte präsident gegen den ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren eröffnet wird
zornig ist er und sucht die
unterstützung seiner fans sein motto wir
gegen die die demokraten wollen die
wählerstimmen von zisch millionen
patriotischen amerikanern annullieren
trans anhänger stehen zu ihm jetzt erst
recht
ich bin froh ihn hier gesehen zu haben
während die demokraten falschen müll
fabrizieren und ihre zeit verplempern
er muss freigesprochen werden trump ist
unser mann im abgeordnetenhaus hatten
zeitgleich die demokraten mit ihrer
mehrheit dort für das
amtsenthebungsverfahren gestimmt nun
müsste die anklage im senat verhandelt
werden doch die vorsitzende der
demokraten droht die anklageschrift nur
weiter zu leiten wenn es dort einen
fairen prozess gebe wir werden sehen wie
sich die dynamik hier entwickelt wir
hoffen natürlich dass wir die
anklageschrift bald dem senat über
rächen können
der streit um die anstehende verhandlung
im senat ist voll entbrannt
derweil mobilisiert trump seine anhänger
in dem er sich als opfer eines
staatsstreichs inszeniert das engagement
es spaltet politik und gesellschaft noch
weiter
das amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen tram
ist eingeleitet
es sieht nach einem hässlichen
präsidentschaftswahlkampf aus königin
elizabeth die zweite hat das britische
parlament in london wieder eröffnet zum
zweiten mal in diesem jahr verlassen die
regierungserklärung von premierminister
johnson
danach habe der austritt aus der eu im
januar höchste priorität außerdem will
johnson verstärkt ins staatliche
gesundheitswesen investieren was
infizierte e-mails anrichten können
zeigte sich heute in frankfurt am main
wer in ein bürgerbüro wollte stand vor
verschlossenen türen in den behörden
ging nichts mehr
nach einem hacker angriff hatte die
stadt ihre it system vom netz genommen
bei online nicht mehr erreichbar weil
ein mitarbeiter eine e-mail mit
gefährlicher software bekommen hatte
axel konrad die details
die türen verschlossen die blicke ratlos
keine pässe keine urkunden selbst keine
beratung heute in ganz frankfurt
ich habe gedacht musste heute die schon
melden ging leider nicht
schade ich finde gerade relativ
erschreckend das ist komplett dicht ist
alle computer in den behörden wurden
heruntergefahren nachdem auf dem pc
eines mitarbeiters ein virus entdeckt
wurde
wir konnten reagieren konnten diesen
rechner vom netz nehmen und nach
derzeitiger erkenntnis ist auch kein
schaden entstanden da wir aber davon
ausgehen müssen dass diese infizierte e
mail auch an andere empfänger versandt
worden ist haben wir vorsichtshalber
alle systeme der stadt frankfurt
heruntergefahren bei dem virus handelt
es sich wohl um den trojaner e moped er
ist in einer gut getimten phishing mails
versteckt der empfänger wird dann
aufgefordert einen anhang zu öffnen und
makros das sind bestimmte programme zu
aktivieren
wer das tut infiziert seinen rechner die
täter haben kontrolle über das system
ermittelt ist besonders gefährlich weil
er
herkömmliche virenprogramme umgehen kann
auch weil er sich permanent selbst
verändert und weil er sich selbst
verbreitet über die kontakte des
infizierten pcs man versucht mit solchen
angriffen daten zu erbeuten oder aber
lösegeld zu erpressen
je nachdem was man gerade erreichen
möchte es geht aber immer um geld was
ihm mut anrichten kann erfährt die uni
gießen derzeit sie ist seit zwei wochen
offline in der bibliothek wird wieder
analog gearbeitet und weil die gesamte
verwaltung am netz hängt haben die
mitarbeiter sorge dass sie ihr gehalt
nicht pünktlich bekommen
ob wichtige daten forschungen der
vergangenen jahrzehnte verloren sind
wird derzeit ermittelt
also augen auf bevor sie eine e-mail
öffnen auf heute de können sie über die
schattenseiten der digitalisierung lesen
wie abhängig wir mittlerweile von der
computerwelt sind schüsse am frühen
abend mitten in moskau vor der zentrale
des inlandsgeheimdienstes fsb über
hintergründe und ausmaß gibt es
widersprüchliche meldungen
offenbar hat ein täter vor dem gebäude
das feuer eröffnet und mindestens einen
dienst mitarbeiter getötet mehrere
verletzt nach angaben des fsb soll auch
der täter erschossen worden sein
der geheimdienst spricht von einem
terroranschlag der konflikt zwischen
russland und der ukraine er ist auch ein
konflikt um gas alle versuche den
künftigen gas transit vertraglich zu
regeln sind gescheitert heute verhandelt
die eu mit beiden parteien in berlin bis
jahresende muss eine lösung her
das ist auch für europa wichtig denn
durch die ukraine fließen pro jahr rund
80 milliarden kubikmeter gas nach westen
im nächsten jahr soll die neue pipeline
nord stream 2 einen teil übernehmen
andreas köhlers berichtet
er ist der vizepräsident der
eu-kommission und er ist die letzte
hoffnung zweier länder die gar nicht in
der eu sind so erbittert streiten
russland und die ukraine über den
künftigen gastransit dass die eu
vermitteln muss und dass sich die
kontrahenten nicht einmal zeigen kein
handschlag bild kein verhandlungsbereit
kein bild dabei klingt präsident putin
bei seiner jährlichen pressekonferenz
heute in moskau zum ersten mal
kompromissbereit
wir sind selbst an einer lösung
interessiert die route durch die ukraine
funktioniert auch wenn sie länger und
teurer ist als die durch die ostsee
die route durch die ostsee sie hat
russlands verhandlungsposition
entscheidend verbessert mit nord stream
2 wird nächstes jahr schon die zweite
pipeline fertig die die ukraine umgeht
alle versuche vor allem aus washington
nord stream 2 zu verhindern dürften zu
spät kommen erst gestern verhängt der
senat auch gegen deutschland sanktionen
aber die bundesregierung reagiert
auffallend mild und mit hinweis auf die
berliner verhandlungen dass diese
gespräche relativ hoffnungsvoll
verlaufen und in diesem zusammenhang
sehr ungünstig lehrerinnen die ukraine
um die transitgebühren käme weil die
verhandlungen erschwert würden weil wir
an anderer stelle hier diese einstellung
zu moslem zwei jahren wenn die
verhandlungen auch heute auch in berlin
scheitern könnte russland schon am
ersten januar den gashahn zudrehen
es ist eine unbequeme frage für die cdu
darf in einem cdu kreisvorstand in
sachsen-anhalt ein mann sitzen
der ordner bei einer neonazi-demo war
der 1 einschläge register trägt und der
bis vor kurzem noch in einem
umstrittenen verein mitglied war sein
kreisvorstand hält ihn für geläutert
andere haben zweifel
heute hat die parteiführung in magdeburg
darüber beraten wie sehr das thema
aufzeigt annette göschel wenig
besinnliches auf dem weihnachtsmarkt bei
der jungen union in magdeburg
diskutieren sie den fall robert morris
und wie ihre mutterpartei damit umgehen
soll
im dem sinne aber gutes halbes jahr
jetzt nicht hals über kopf rausgeworfen
wurde wenn man was machen wir dann reden
wir hier über ein
parteiausschlussverfahren alles was ich
von ihnen gehört habe wird für mich
nicht so als ob er im kern hinter
unseren positionen steht denn
cdu-kreisvorstand robert moritz hat 2011
als ordner an einer neonazi demo
teilgenommen davon distanziert er sich
zwar mittlerweile dennoch trägt er noch
immer dieses tattoo drei übereinander
gelegte hakenkreuze aus dem unter
rechtsextremismus verdacht stehenden
verein juni tritt er erst vor wenigen
tagen aus nach öffentlichem druck sein
kreisverband anhalt-bitterfeld
vertrauten möritz doch bundeschefin
kramp karrenbauer droht
von ihrem truppenbesuch in zypern ich
habe ja gestern schon mal gesagt der
kreisverband hat vertrauen eingeräumt
und sollte sich jetzt herausstellen dass
dieses vertrauen missbraucht worden ist
dann bin ich der auffassung müssen
entsprechende konsequenzen eben auch
gezogen werden beobachter sehen die cdu
in sachsen anhalt vor einer zerreißprobe
grob zusammengefasst kann man sagen dass
es in der cdu im landesverband in
sachsen anhalt einen rechten flügel gibt
der durchaus derzeit
auflockerungsübungen nach rechts
betreibt also nach rechts insbesondere
im hinblick auf die afd
beim krisentreffen der cdu-spitze wurde
eben beschlossen dass moritz in den
nächsten tagen seine rechtsextremen
aktivitäten aufdecken muss und sich
glaubhaft distanziert andernfalls hat es
einen parteiausschluss zufolge in der
slowakei hat ein spektakulärer prozess
begonnen es geht um den mord an dem
enthüllungsjournalisten jan kozak vor
fast zwei jahren wurden der 27 jährige
und seine verlobte erschossen
er hatte über geschäfte zwischen der
italienischen mafia und slowakischen
politikern recherchiert der doppelmord
löste massendemonstrationen aus
rücktritte in der regierung er hat das
land massiv erschüttert britta hilpert
sie gehen jeden tag zum grab ihres
sohnes er wurde nur 27 jahre alt jan
kozak ermordet am 21 februar 2018 wegen
seiner arbeit journalist
ich bezweifle dass uns der prozess gegen
seine mörder erleichtert aber es wurde
ja ermittelt dass sie weitere morde
planten schon allein deshalb ist es
wichtig sie zu verurteilen um das zu
verhindern
heute beginnt der prozess gegen die
mutmaßlichen täter helfer und
auftraggeber kurz jaxx eltern werden
wohl monate auf ein urteil warten ist
der auftragsmord an cusack und seiner
verlobten löste 2018 massenproteste aus
für die pressefreiheit und gegen die
mafiösen verstrickungen der
sozialdemokratischen regierung
ministerpräsident fico musste
zurücktreten
sein freund der vorbestrafte
geschäftsmann marion coach ist
mutmaßlicher auf
er hatte das mordopfer cusack in einem
telefonat bedroht bank gut weg sie
werden der erste sein der mord habe die
slowakei polarisiert meint man in kues
redaktion kurz nach dem mord sind die
politiker den journalisten anders
begegnet heute so fürchte ich ist es
wieder schlechter
es kann ihr so enden wie in orbáns
ungarn
dieser prozess hat mehr als eine
strafrechtliche bedeutung für die
slowakei geht es auch darum zu zeigen
dass justiz und presse unabhängig
funktionieren
wegen der immer noch verheerenden
buschbrände in australien hat der
bundesstaat new south wales erneut einen
einwöchigen notstand verhängt die
behörden können so schneller geld und
einsatzkräfte mobilisieren wind und
extreme hitze fachen die brände seit
wochen immer wieder an
in sydney gab es proteste gegen die
mangelnde klimapolitik der regierung und
gegen conny minister morrison der im
urlaub ist während es im land brett die
kinder der müll und der tod so heiß des
unicef foto des jahres
es zeigt wie nie maria 13 jahre alt bei
der arbeit im hafen von manila aus der
verdreckten bock zwischen kinder
plastikflaschen
wenn sie glück haben bekommen sie dafür
am ende des tages 50 bis 90 cent geld
das ihre familien im slum zum überleben
brauchen
kinder sind das wertvollste was wir
haben sagt die schirmherrin des
wettbewerbs und frau des
bundespräsidenten elke büdenbender und
die einhaltung der kinderrechte sei
aufgabe für alle hat zu recht
absolut jetzt bist du dran mit sport und
ich habe ein schönes erfolgserlebnis
vier tage nach platz zwei in der staffel
freuen sich die deutschen biathleten
über den ersten saisonsieg benedikt doll
gewannen zum auftakt des weltcups in
frankreich den sprint und zeigte sich
selbst sehr überrascht
benedikt doll bedankt sich beim fairen
publikum hier in frankreich freut sich
über seinen zweiten weltcupsieg
ich habe mich heute morgen doch
irgendwie nicht ganz so frisch gefühlt
so ein bisschen im hals irgendwie von
der trockenen luft ich weiß es auch
nicht
naja ich hätte absolut ich gedacht dass
es heute für diese top platzierung
reicht die war bis heute das fehlerfreie
schießen sowohl liegend als auch stehend
fünf treffer dazu die zweitschnellste
laufzeit das podest komplettierte als
zweiter der norweger tarjei bö links im
bild und kaffee ohg aus frankreich mit
rang drei morgen der sprint der damen
von 14 uhr an live in zdf sportextra
vorher bereits ski alpin im livestream
und am abend live hier auch bei uns im
zweiten der beginn des letzten fußball
bundesliga spieltages der hinrunde
zwischen hoffenheim und borussia
dortmund der bvb mit dem ziel an der
tabellenspitze weiter mitzumischen musst
dabei kurzfristig auf kapitän marco reus
verzichten der sich einen
muskelfaserriss zugezogen hat es scheint
eine zähe juristische hängepartie zu
werden denn russland wehrt sich gegen
die vier jahre sperre die wegen der
doping- manipulation von der wada
ausgesprochen wurde
der aufsichtsratsvorsitzende der
russischen anti doping agentur hat
erwartetes zu verkünden
wir haben entschieden gegen das urteil
der welt-anti-doping-agentur einspruch
einzulegen und werden einen
entsprechenden brief als sie formulieren
dies bedeutet dass die vierjährige
sperre gegen russland vorerst nicht in
kraft treten kann
unterstützung kommt von höchster stelle
aus dem kreml wo staatschef putin sich
heute auch zu diesem thema äußert
bestrafungen sollten individueller natur
sein
eine sippenhaft die saubere sportler
einschließe es sei ungerecht
ein juristisches tauziehen wird nun
beginnen das erst ein urteil des cas des
internationalen sportgerichtshofs
beenden wird gut möglich dass dies bis
zu den olympischen spielen in tokio
dauern wird
und die beginnen ende juli so viel
dankeschön das wetter fühlt sich zwar
noch nicht wie julian aber definitiv
auch nicht wie dezember es wird massa
und sogar bis zu 18 grad warm mehr
gleich von ostern terry marietta slomka
freut sich auf sie im heute journal um
viertel vor zehn und wir freuen uns wenn
sie morgen wieder lust haben dabei zu
sein einen schönen abend noch auf
wiedersehen
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das ruhige wetter
hat allmählich ein ende denn von westen
her da komme allmählich tiefs richtung
mitteleuropa und eines dieser regen
bender was zu einem tief gehört erreicht
nun auch deutschland und bringt etwa bis
zur mitte regen mit schauen wir auf die
details in der nacht im westen schon mal
wollten verdichtung aber es bleibt
insgesamt trocken es bildet sich
teilweise nebel im osten ist es
sternenklar temperaturen liegen zwischen
minus 2 grad im südosten deutschlands
und 10 grad im westen
im westen generell deutlich milder vor
allem richtung niederrhein moore am
vormittag verdichtet sich die bewölkung
weiter und wir haben es hier mit regen
zu tun
ansonsten ist es relativ sonnig vor
allem im osten und zwischen bayerischer
wald und alpenrand hier also viel
sonnenschein
ja und das hat teilweise mit etwas mit
film zu tun hier ist der wind ziemlich
stark direkt an den alpen sonst auch
sturmböen im westen dazu kräftiger regen
im osten ist es dagegen relativ
freundlich bei föhn gibt es hohe
temperaturen bis 18 grad im
berchtesgadener land sonst 7 grad an der
ostsee und etwa 14 grad im süden
deutschlands die nächsten tage am
samstag beruhigt sich das wetter etwas
nach osten noch regen bei fünf bis zwölf
grad und dann wird es deutlich
durchwachsen ab sonntag ein schöner
abend